well in the vast majority of the
countries we work in we obviously work
in at the under the agreement of the
government and the government will have
a certain role in in determining how
NGOs we work in certain countries where
we're working much more at the
grassroots level down at where we're
perhaps not that much engaged directly
with government but in countries that
have you know reasonably established
governmental structures we very much
work within those structures and because
we see ourselves as bringing you know in
a sense at one level filling gaps that
government can't do but I think are the
role of an agency like concern is very
much to be I think a catalyst to help
bring together different agency and
we're pretty good at that maybe the
Irish background comes into into this
but helping facilitating people work
well together and I think the other
thing that we do particularly well and
this is really our starting point in
many of the to put in in all of the
programs we do is we start by trying to
listen to the very poor people what are
their needs you know what are the issues
that they are trying to achieve what of
their resources can they bring to
working towards their improved welfare
and how can somehow or other we fit in
and in a sense harness those
capabilities of those very resourceful
people and so I think in terms of our
engagement in any of these countries it
is at this number of different levels at
at the level of the very much the
household and the community level right
up to the top level where we would be
trying in many cases where it's feasible
it's not always visible where many trade
cases trying to influence government
policy many times through partners
through civil society within the
countries we work in influence policy at
governmental level two
favorable toward tour support
the fundamental approach doesn't change
I think you go in and you you do try to
understand the context you're working in
and then you try to design your
intervention to deal with that put in an
emergency situation you do have to act
quickly and so therefore you know
there's some level of consultation but
at the end of the day there is an
urgency when you get the job done and
this is where I think experience comes
into play concern has been in operation
now for 40 years we've accumulated a
great deal of experience as to how to
operate in emergencies but the basic
principles of listening to the people of
quick and effective action there they
remained whether it's in emergencies or
developing situation